I don't think we actually talked about
the organization itself we talked about
uh tax exempt status which is really
important we talked about some of the
control like through the propaganda
control
of what's out there it's actually
interesting that you said that like
the Scientology has pretty much lost the
battle with the internet oh yeah
um which is kind of inspiring that it's
hard to defeat the internet
but then there's like Bots there
I think if you're sophisticated I'm not
sure that's true but if you're not it's
kind of remarkable they haven't been
able to capitalize on these bot armies
because there's one thing that they have
it's a lot of tax-free money that they
got nothing else better to do it yeah
right so you can invest you know they
just they should give you a call like
they just don't have the right people
apparently
uh but that said how do they wield uh
influence with government agencies with
you've talked about uh the local police
yeah uh enforcement uh also federal
agencies anything that is the one way
they effectively put their money to use
is lobbyists and attorneys
um you know judges very rarely have they
ever been able just to get a politician
on their side it's the behind the scenes
people you know Greta Van susteren's a
very high level long-term Scientologist
and her husband I always get it wrong
it's either Jim Cole or John Cole I
always get it wrong uh he's a very
powerful attorney who has a lot uh
wields a lot of influence behind the
scenes
and that's just one example like the
reason why that's an interesting example
is because he's actually a Scientologist
and he travels in those circles
Scientology though its money goes to
good use by hiring non-scientologists
retired judges attorneys lobbyists it
really is how they get almost anything
done like miscavige himself is not
hobnobbing and glad hand and shaking
hands and meeting these folks it's the
non-scientologist professionals
who work behind the scenes on
scientology's behalf
can you describe the Dynamics of that
how that actually happens like like why
why would the why would the police
department work on behalf of Scientology
I meant more the courts and Regulators
not the police department but well for
example it can come down to something as
simple as this sign in Clearwater
Scientology hires Clearwater Police to
do off-duty work for them they pay like
three times the normal off-duty rate so
they will even though I'm not aware of
anyone on the Clearwater PD who's
actually a Scientologist they basically
end up with they would call them allies
or safe points right people who like
will literally operate a Scientology
spies you know if someone comes in and
follows a report about some child sex
case someone in the Clearwater PD is
calling Sarah Heller at the office of
special Affairs at the flank Latin base
to let her know hey heads up we got a
thing coming in and then Scientology can
run around and go talk to all the
scientologists who have knowledge about
this and either get them out of clear
water you know so it's not like uh
direct explicit corruption but more just
uh friends and co-workers yeah
integrated deeply in the in the
community yeah I call it soft corruption
so on another example you have
um the mayor of Clearwater Frank Hibbard
um well he used to when when he won his
recent election he stepped down from
some of these nonprofits that he served
on but the nonprofits that he served on
also gets millions of dollars of
donations from some of scientology's
richest Clearwater members right you
have one of the mayor's best friends Joe
Burdette literally a paid lobbyist for
Scientology so that creates a chilling
effect
on anyone who's going to be talking
smack about scientology because
his friends are on their damn payroll so
um I call it soft corruption it's not
illegal
it's not illegal
um but it's how Scientology wields
influence and what's what's ironic is
that a lot of these people who work on
Scientology behalf actually secretly
hate Scientology
they kind of see through it but it's
part of the community I mean it's deeply
integrated in the community and there's
financial leverage
um are you ever afraid
I mean afraid for your well-being afraid
for your
ability to function in society because
of the pressures from Scientology no is
that because you're genetically
malfunctioning or or mentally or or is
it or is there speaking out as a kind of
protection I think it's one of those
things that once you've seen behind the
curtain you see The Wizard of Oz is just
a silly man you just don't have any fear
now it's one of these things like people
say oh you're so brave and I go huh
what's that quote bravery is you know
being a soldier and being afraid and
going in any way
it's not rapes running if you don't
think nothing's gonna happen to you like
so I'm just trying to like I do not hold
myself up as an example of Bravery
because yeah I it's not like oh they
could destroy me but I don't care no
there's not a damn thing they can do to
me and it's one of that's one of the
reasons I continue to put out content
every day to just basically go hey still
here
I dare you to try to do something about
it but you can't and hope that that also
serves as kind of an example for other
people to go if this Schmo can do it and
they can't do anything else to him then
maybe I can do it too because I would
love it I would love there for be a 20
channels where former scientologists
talk about their experience I mean that
is bravery because what happens is fear
seeps in even if it's not grounded in
reality but at the same time like uh you
know
um my grandfather who uh fought in in
World War II I mean the story is I mean
he was very convinced and sure most of
the people he fought alongside would
died he was a machine gunner but he
believed that bullets can't hit him
right what he said
well you know he was right
right because he survived so there's
some sense like you're never biased that
he's like just like yours like I'm not
brave I just the bullets can't hit me
I mean there's a dark kind of Truth to
that there's some you know it's like um
it's it's a feedback loop where if you
have the confidence and you push on
forward and you're brave in that way to
not let fear see pen and affect you it
actually gives you less things to be
scared about and yeah I mean but that
initial few steps might be uh for people
it might be a very difficult stuff to
take to talk about publicly the fear was
knowing how the family was going to be
destroyed and trying to prevent that I
was terrified of that happening
but it happened
there's nothing left to be afraid of and
that's kind of the thing like they
created this Beast and the same is true
for Mark Headley the same is true for
Mike rinder I I said they've essentially
created a scientology-proof virus
Scientology resistant strain by throwing
everything they have at us for so many
years
they have just through natural selection
created people who just do not give a
damn about anything they could or would
do and maybe there is something a little
wrong with me because when I get a phone
call from someone like I just got this
phone call about you and it's clear that
it's Scientology Pi is doing work behind
the scenes I get really excited
I get really excited I don't get nervous
I'm like oh no it's happening like oh
yeah this is going to be exciting I'm
like okay because everything they try to
do to me
I'm gonna figure out how to reflect it
back on them and make them look
ridiculous and that pills in comparison
to the separating from family exactly
what is there is there parts of your
family that you've lost because of
Scientology
just yeah
if you
foreign
in the aftermath show
was talking about me and my twin brother
it's just a pretty horrible story it's
just a pretty horrible story so I do
have a younger brother who's still in
Scientology and disconnected from me but
I never had much of a relationship
um with that brother
um
really to begin with right
um but my twin brother died when I was
like 23 or 24.
and that was without any question a
direct result of
um
our Scientology experience you know he
died in a car accident that wasn't
technically his fault or anything like
he wasn't even the one driving but uh
the fact the the specific fact of his
death was not meaning like the the fact
and the manner of his death and wasn't
like specifically because of Scientology
but our story and how uh where our
relationship got to
and how he was even in a position
of having something like that happen to
him is directly attributable to
Scientology
do you think about him miss him
it's part of what you're doing in memory
of him
for sure
man this is I mean you know we were
identical twins can you imagine two of
me
I could barely handle one
I love it
uh losing him would that be the darkest
moment in this whole journey of
Scientology for you
two moments would equal the darkest
moment it it would be that
and also just the period of you know
six nine twelve months of impending doom
knowing that my wife's whole family was
going to be obliterated
and that there's nothing we could do
about it
and uh
and kind of telling ourselves every step
of the way it wasn't really going to
happen
you know
um and I really felt like
you ever watch the Ozarks
I felt like Marty bird now this was
happening before the Ozarks but when I
watched the Ozarks and I see that
character
the entire world is crumbling down
around him and all he can
oh I did like
all right what's the next step
I watch Marty bird and I go that's my
[__] spirit animal
because you can only control what you
can control
and um you can't keep Scientology from
destroying your family and and literally
like I it's funny I mentioned the show a
lot because I watched that and I go like
that's exactly how I felt you know I
talk about this six months or nine
twelve months whatever it was of
impending doom it's not like I was an
emotional wreck during that time you
know in private I was but it's not like
I was just freaking out it was like the
sun's gonna come up tomorrow the World's
Gonna keep spinning I can't control it
this is hard I can't believe this is
happening
but tomorrow's a new day
um I've never personally even at the
darkest times I've never experienced
anything that I would characterize as
depression certainly not ever any
suicidal thoughts or anything even in
the darkest of times I and again this
one thing I go is it because it's
Scientology or is it just me there
really is an emotional detachment
there almost has to be and it's a cold
calculation what what are my options
what do I do here and then once I figure
out the answer to that question I'm
actually quite chipper and happy
you know like that's sort of my default
like you could give me six horrible
options once I figure out the best of
those six I'm gonna feel like I just had
a pretty good day that's brilliant
because I was just watching Ozarks is so
stressful it is right it's so stressful
watching it is it
and uh he usually finds a way
and usually it is a set of really bad
options and it's one of the bad options
what's the best of the bad options and
he almost gets pissed off at everyone
around him for being so pouty about it
oh
but you know what's that show again the
same way again oh but you know it's like
you know it's still simmering there
right under the surface like pretty damn
close to the surface do you know what I
mean yeah yeah and um
people sometimes ask about recovery and
whatnot and like what does that look
like and what does that mean and it sort
of goes back to kind of the emotional
Detachment is I go what the [__] does
recovery even mean if you're an
alcoholic and you're recovering you know
what that means I used to drink I don't
drink now well I used to be an occult
and I'm not an occult now how else am I
supposed to feel about this for someone
to be like it seems like you've
recovered what the [__] does that even
mean like I'm sure some academic has an
answer to that question I'm not someone
who particular I don't spend any time
thinking about that my recovery is
success and a little bit of trolling and
revenge yeah but mostly success you know
what does it mean to be a recovered
former cult member what you don't cry
when people ask you about your brother I
don't know what it means
um I've never had therapy but not
because I'm still like against it from
Scientology I just like
I'm not gonna pay to talk to someone do
you know where else I could do that
Scientology now I know there's a lot of
people going like oh boy I know it's a
lot I'm not [__] on therapy
I would rather have a beer with my
friend and talk about this [__] yeah
than talk to a professional for 200 an
hour as a kind of therapy yeah yeah yeah
listen that's the import part of the
reason I do this podcast is talking to
people that you care about
the that you're close with this is a
really powerful powerful thing but yeah
I don't know what recovery looks like
and success to you is defined just be to
find happiness find happiness outside
the closed bubble that defines What
happiness looks like a Scientology if I
can make my kids happy that's success to
me